the Lone Survivor of last year's
nine-car crash in North Las Vegas joined
the city to honor those killed with a
tree planting ceremony today they say
it's not just about remembering lives
lost but also raising awareness so
something like this doesn't happen again
still hear the screams The Echoes the
cries Tiffany Noel remembers the horror
of the crash she survived last year even
my family saw
me laying face down in the dirt when
this incident happened nine people were
killed including seven from the
Zacharias family when 59-year-old Gary
Robinson ran a red light going over 100
miles per hour here at Commerce and
Cheyenne one year ago I think it's
important for us to remember the tragedy
and to remember the Sacramento's family
on Sunday Noel joined the city of North
Las Vegas to plant trees in their honor
at Craig Ranch Park these are seven
innocent lives that were going on about
their normal day and this horrific
accident happened mayor Pamela
goins-brown and councilman Isaac Brown
say this is a way to remember their
lives while also raising awareness most
of fatalities can be attributed to
excessive speeding and to various states
of inebriation Noel says as she
continues
continue of that day
will help others be more
we normalize car crashes as if they are
accidents and stay safe on our Valley
roads it's not like spilling juice
accidents or car crashes are preventable
now else as Craig Ranch Park was the
last place the Zacharias family went
before they were killed which is why the
ceremony was held there